alors jean louis vous arrivez tout de
suite on est à la fiche 69 donc on était
la question de la fiche 69 vous savez
que les rôles sont inversés et c'est
vous jean-louis qu'ils allaient me poser
une question
tu connais les chefs d'arrondissement du
livres au
nom
[Applaudissements]
de la culture à la télé et
encore moi je suis un des plus cultivé
il s'agit là ni
bien dire pour leur rebond soir jean
louis danvoye l'a1 vous êtes une sorte
de moujik de la musique d'une certaine
façon en
superman c'est pas mal comme formule
magique de la musique ensemble c'est un
paysan russe
titouan
ça vous gêne de faire la promo à la télé
non j'aime beaucoup ça
[Applaudissements]
ce que j'ai lu des propos de vous pas
désobligeant pour moi mais très très
très désobligeant pour mais bon mes
confrères nous étions de parfaire leurs
émissions si vous n'avez pas envie de
faire de promo à la télé si vous n'allez
pas en faire parce que vu ce que j'avais
le choix c'était vous photo jl ouais je
vous ai choisis vous c'est gentil
les saloperies sur fogiel j'aurais pu
dire sur vous aussi oui c'est vrai
soyez fier à tyrosse voilà c'est avec
votre copain là il n'y est pas allé de
main morte avec fogiel a way les wagons
pas stéphane avec vous ives aussi alors
moi ce que j'ai lu c'est votre copain
mais manqueront pas stéphane sur vous il
va d'abord dire ce qu
on va voir votre copain l'a donc il dit
en parlant de marc olivier fogiel il se
trémousse tellement on dirait qu'il a
collé un gode sur sa chaise c'est nul ça
sympa non là vous serez plus obligé d'y
aller chez fogiel vous savez ça
maintenant tu ici m'a invité choix je
vais y aller ah bon mais il faut par
contre il faut que je vous assassine
avec les blacks de mon copain c'était
d'accord
mais vous épargner pas le métier non
plus en parlant du patron d'universal
pascal [ __ ]
c'est à dire marquer ses membres vous
êtes le seul en fait ce qui est génial
c'est le seul qui des trucs au fait que
c'est drôle quoi bah ouais ça que tu
lance donc pascal [ __ ] le patron
d'universal vous avez dit quel look de
charcutier il a normalisé gala devrait
dé couper des têtes de veau c'est génial
[Applaudissements]
en revanche l'an dernier vous dites pas
que des vaches qui me dit aussi des
trucs très vrai vous avez dit c'est vrai
que la chanson française ressemble de
plus en plus à la variété internationale
de moins en moins d'auteur compositeur
interprète est de plus en plus
d'interprètes
dans les maisons de disques font
absolument ce qu'elles veulent ça c'est
vrai c'est bientôt vous trouvez ça
pertinents ouais je vous soit pertinent
d'autant plus que vous d'autant plus que
vous ajoutez des juillet prenez une
photo tient non je trouve sa pertinence
de temps qu'il vous a ajouté que ce sont
tous des chanteurs de balle je trouve ça
assez bien je dis c'est que finalement
ce qui est typique de cette nouvelle
race de chanteur ce sont les chanteurs
québécois parce qu'ils sont trop fort
est parce que je pense que la langue
française c'est une langue de c'est une
langue de la de l'intimité et de la
passion et du plaisir c'est non mais
plutôt une langue chuchoter c'est vrai
que c'est
vrai que les gens qui parlent fort ont
du mal à penser finement et je prépare
le chanteur c'est un peu par contre si
tu veux parler un tout petit peu plus
fort parce que moi je n'attend pas
je parlerai
john mara 12 mois le plx tout ce
qui s'appelle baby karni birds sur le
sur le loft vous n'avez pas aimé love
story vous pas tellement je suis pas
aimé ça c'est comment la presse et
comment les gens se sont engouffrés là
dedans vrai devenu une sorte
d'indifférence de sport national du
commenter cette chose assez médiocre
c'était un peu humiliant pour tout le
monde et c'est vrai tout le monde
s'engage et là dedans il ya un type très
connue au monde se bat daniel
schneidermann qui donne des leçons de
morale à tout le monde toutes les
semaines bien il a écrit le spectacle en
parlant du loft le spectacle de
télévision le plus neuf de plus créatif
et le plus intéressant programmer ces
dernières années sur les écrans français
face à ces derniers temps le monde en
connaît ils sont assez fin ouais ouais
t'as remarqué oui j'ai remarqué c'est le
même boli m'bolhi 60 selon 70 ou non une
légère à lui
vous avez réservé celui-là alors eh ben
oui alors vous avez d'autres fiches cela
vous donne un paquet fille j'en ai plein
pour le oui non en fait je vous dire
pourquoi j'ai pris une piste chaude
parce que vous êtes un titre quand même
assez paradoxale d'un côté vous êtes
énervé par ces chanteurs qu'on lance
comme des savonnettes là vous dites moi
je bosse pendant des heures avec mon
piano ma guitare et tout moi je suis un
vrai quoi je travaille je me donne du
mal et en fait quand on voit comment
vous avez enregistré ce disque que vous
promotionner aujourd'hui le moujik et sa
femme vous dites que vous l'avez
enregistré en douze heures ouais
comme dylan deux heures par jour
dans mon avis des mecs qui met de trois
ans pour faire un album les branleurs
ont pas deux
deux drops en faire un homme comme
stills énimie son parent tuer laurent
voulzy la mi-novembre faire son album
c'est du marketing
au reste du torrent ou faisais du foot à
la piscine
le nom jeune âge et des pétards
non je mets les musiciens
[Musique]
c'est fini ça
pas vous êtes bonnes critiques c'est
essentiel d'être content
là comme d'habitude libération les
inrocks
comment sa libération et the rock mais
malheureux il ya des centaines de médias
il ya un pack 2 c'est vous qui vous
ouvre ses filiales voulez vous lisez que
ces domaines et pas du tout de poudre
ingénue elle aussi
avaliser l ancien dépôt des photos non
non je lis j'ai vu qu' il y avait toutes
les femmes 18 paires guerre des clips
toutes les femmes de l disent du bien de
vous vous êtes très très très aimé des
femmes
katherine pancol pascale clark que
christine angot
car denis verdini de ma copine car vous
aimez les femmes elles vous le rendent
bien
que je ne viens pas ce que vous l'aimez
sauf qu'il a une voix
envoûtante j'aime beaucoup aussi des
shows comme la fumée mais je les aime
beaucoup
c'est vrai vous dit quand je tombe
amoureux c'est une opportunité pour
changer chaque fille ne chamboulent je
prends ces gestes je change d'autres
toilettes si elle se lève plus tard je
me cale sur son rythme si elle s'habille
en grenat je vais m'acheter des trucs
grenat ses profits c'est ça l'amour
c'est l'amour c'est un vrai qu'une forme
de l'amour
c'est pas en forme qui toi moi je
mettrais bien moi ça va comme d'habitude
elles sont pas terribles ces questions
c'est à des questionnements j'aurais
mieux fait d'aller je suis fou j aime ça
c'est sûr
c'est quand un prochain album c'est
quand dans deux jours
vous êtes adulé par la critique c'est
vrai et par le public ouais nan mais les
ventes ne suivent pas comment ça se fait
je vend 100 milles à chaque fois ça me
va très bien te suffit récurrence de
trois albums en même temps
tu paies 300000 comment ça se fait que
vous soyez pas un chanteur populaire
ce qui est cher et rare ouais
vous passer en radio man entassons et
sont obligés de passer des chansons
françaises à la radio n'en
fait pas des
barbus à petit budget pour faire ce
disque là non c'est de la blague ça j'ai
un budget énorme normal parce que votre
maison de disques il paraît qu'ils vous
donneront deux fois - ci marche pas vous
dise vas-y amuse-toi faire une demi
audience qui lorsqu en fait
c'est un peu le parent pauvre dans votre
maison de disques n'ont pas du tout non
non je suis le chouchou mais par exemple
vous fait la promo vous êtes dans un
très bel hôtel pour recevoir les
journalistes et après vous allez dormir
dans un hôtel moins bien c'est vrai bah
oui c'est normal
pourquoi tu parles inverse
vers 18 donne pas un bel hôtel lutter
jour ça que je comprends pas non mais je
sais pas enfin je peux à peine de
dépenser des fortunes dans des chambres
d'hôtel par un lycéen lee c'est vrai que
voulez vous installer dans le sud par
exemple question idiote comme ça mais
qui peut vous donne l'occasion de vous
exprimer
oui oui
je ne suis pas encore truction
jeudi pensais je dois quitter l'auvergne
à une question non je sais pas encore on
ne pense pas
est ce que tu veux jouer ou non
maintenant je vais bien je peux jouer
non mais qu six mois j'étais un mauvais
client n'était pas du tout
alors est ce que jean louis murat vous
êtes prêts pour une interview jugement
dernier
[Applaudissements]
jean louis murat
ces jugements dernière mais j'en ai eu
ras vous pensé à la mort une demi-heure
par jour
ah bon donc vous êtes prêts pour
l'interview jugement dernier
jean louis murat quand tu étais petit
as tu essayé de regarder sous le bureau
de ta maîtresse
jamais
il était plein
as-tu enfermer des élèves de sexe
féminin dans les cabinets jamais il
était en plein air
jean louis murat
as-tu jouer au docteur avec tes copains
jamais il n'était jamais malade c'est
bien merci
jean louis murat avec ce professeur
d'anglais qui t'a fait lire coridon es
tu sûr qu'il ne sais vraiment rien passé
sexuellement tu veux dire bien sûr que
non
jean louis murat
as-tu utiliser sa notoriété pour obtenir
des avantages particuliers
des fois les bonnes places pour les
autres ça absorbe le tue encore des
substances illicites jamais
jamais jamais tu as chopin justement
c'est bien correct on tente purgatoire
un éventuel m'est étranger
est il arrivé d'avoir envie de la femme
d'un autre
jamais gêné principe
est il arrivé de trompeta fable jamais
gêné principe est il arrivé de trompeta
maîtresse
c'est jamais une maîtresse
jean louis murat as tu ne serait ce
qu'une fois
emmerder le monde par plaisir
jamais
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu